it's a guidance to the pious and then I give you immediately a parallel verse what's
the parallel verse my Mercy encompasses all things everyone loves this
verse
continue it though I'll prescribe it
I'll ordain it for those who have tawa
all right and I I've told you this story many times before that I was at
a a
talk
and the professor gets up there one of these Prof Islamic Studies professors and someone raises
a
and says what do you say about very good people who aren't on your religion right
very good people who aren't of your religion so she's a
the question has already judged them as being good she she's already made herself a judge
it's built in the question and the guy he's being political so he says the Quran
says my Mercy encompasses all things
now long young little boy
just a 14 15y old boy
he goes to him could you finish what the verse
says
finish what the verse says I shall ordain it on the people who have tawa
resist Temptations humble yourself accept what you may not like
okay all of this is the only way to get this mercy so it encompasses all
things means what means for example
uh there are enough lexuses for all of us
doesn't mean you're going to all get them
right it's going to go to the one who can pay for it
so my Mercy it encompasses all things that means no one's too big for Allah's mercy
no sinner is so bad that he can't get Allah's Mercy
however who's going to get it those who have tawa what is really tawa the fight
to resist
Temptations all right that's the the real Crux of what tawa is
okay and then it's described who are the people of tawa they pay the the prescribed
arms they believe in our Revelation they follow the messenger okay
uh the they Command right forbid wrong
uh
makes good things lawful make bad things unlawful relieve burden
okay he's saying what this is what the prophet does but this is what we're supposed
to do too